what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the conclusion of
annihilation Conquest specifically the
question that a lot of you guys have at
least I see me have because honestly I'm
recording all of these before the first
one even goes live where you guys are
probably wondering how it was that
Ultron managed to return okay so here's
the thing this all goes into a story
called Mighty Avengers and in fact we're
going to reference a lot of older comics
in this particular really this video
that we're doing because there's a lot
of references to older things to make it
make sense the idea behind this is most
of you guys know at least if you're
familiar with Marvel Comics is that Hank
Pym was the one who originally created
Ultron right and creating the Ultron
Singularity the robot like basically
became Skynet immediately deemed that
organic life was a problem and it wanted
to destroy basically everybody on Earth
this ultimately led to the Ultron robot
escaping going through different
versions fighting the Avengers on and
off again and different things along
those lines in Mighty Avengers there was
a story where Ultron had actually taken
over the armor of Tony Stark you ended
up having Ultron defeated where it was
believed he was destroyed the reality is
that the consciousness of Ultron base
basically fled into space eventually it
encountered the Phalanx race and when it
did because the failings are akin to the
Borg from Star Trek Philadelphia guys
who are familiar with that in the sense
that they Traverse all of creation and
their desire is to basically consume and
convert all organic life into themselves
which we'll talk about a little more
here in a moment because we're going to
reference Jonathan Hickman's run on the
X-Men because that's their purpose
Ultron basically ended up subduing
taking over the Phalanx and then
becoming their leader now this was
particularly important and the reason
why is because the Phalanx had been
leaderless for quite some time and the
reason for this is that in Marvel Comics
what you have is a group called The
technarchy then you have the Phalanx now
Marvel's been a little murky over the
years in terms of the relationship
between the two for example in an
eyelash in Conquest Marvel establishes
that the Phalanx are an evolutionary
offshoot of the technorchy whereas in
previous Comics They Don't Really
indicate that either of them hail from
any similar origin at all outside of the
fact that like they look the same so it
really changes based on what comic you
are reading but the general gist of this
is that because Ultron is himself a
robot and is really probably the most
advanced robot in the entirety of the
Marvel Universe it wasn't difficult for
him to subdue the Phalanx more because
the Phalanx were looking for an
individual to basically guide them
because Ultron presented himself in that
way that's exactly what the Phalanx did
they basically Allied themselves with
Ultron and they called it a day now for
the other side of things that are going
on here what we've been doing of course
is kind of bouncing back and forth
between the early formations of the
Guardians of the Galaxy as well as Ron
the accuser and so on this is when all
these storylines basically come to a
head that with Ron and the accuser
basically establishing or using these 15
000 centuries of the cree Empire to
launch as a direct assault against the
Phalanx with the centuries themselves
being protected by praxagora from
basically the influence of the phalange
right from the Phalanx just taking them
over that's one of the assaults that
takes place the other one that takes
place is that the bombs in the Babel
Spire are for the most part successfully
detonated in the sense of the Babel
Spire is not totally destroyed but the
battle Spire is destroyed enough to
where it weakens the force field that
surrounds all of cree's space so nobody
can get in and nobody can get out now
one of the funny things about this is
that Ronnie accuser establishes that
because of the power of the cree
centuries within a matter of minutes
they will have liberated the entire
world that Ron and the accuser and his
forces are on from the influence of the
Phalanx once they get to holla they
should be able to basically eliminate
all the failings on that world within 10
minutes right it's kind of crazy how
powerful the centuries are and that's
one of the things that I've been telling
you guys the centuries are immensely
powerful when it comes to to Marvel
Comics and the cree race but the crazy
thing about this is that as the high
evolutionary is looking over all this
stuff right basically going through all
these memories of Ultron what he
realizes is that Ultron was well aware
of the high evolutionary he knew exactly
who the high evolutionary was and it
basically manipulated all these
different circumstances to ensure that
Adam Warlock was woken up that Adam
Warlock was awakened and the high
evolutionary skills could be utilized by
the Phalanx it's really just Ultron
tricking the high evolutionary himself
now that's one of the things that's
really amazing about the character of
Ultron in the comics that was not
carried over very well in the Age of
Ultron film from the MCU Ultron himself
is incredibly intelligent when he was
originally created it was literally just
I am a robot and I do robotic things and
blah blah blah blah I'm a villain of the
week I want to kill superheroes nothing
too unique about that but what Marvel
Comics has done is over the years every
time Ultron faced off against the
Avengers he learned and he expanded his
capabilities and that's why he would
always come back more capable and almost
destroy the Avengers every time really
it was one of those things where it was
like because it's an Avengers comic and
we have to always publish Avengers
Comics we can't have Ultron kill the
team that's why stories like Age of
Ultron from Marvel Comics are considered
alternate reality stories because in
truth Ultron could do that pretty easily
it wouldn't be too difficult for him to
annihilate the entirety of Earth's
superheroes fairly easily given how
powerful and how capable he is but
because of the fact that it's Marvel
Comics and they always got to publish
Avengers Comics they don't kill off the
Avengers team
it kind of makes sense you know it'd be
kind of cool though if they did I'd be
interested to see what happens but
nonetheless right Ultron and his forces
again have kind of manipulated
everything that's going on and so while
you do have the Guardians who again are
able to detonate the Babel's fire the
bigger campaign here for Ultron is to
actually switch bodies with Adam Warlock
or at least to take over the body of
Adam Warlock now this is not something
where Dan Abner is just pulling it out
of his ass in fact this was a major plot
point for Ultron way back in the day so
back in 1977 with Avengers issue number
160 it was a story that was written by a
gym shooter and George Perez and the
whole idea behind this is that the
eighth version of Ultron meaning Ultron
having recreated himself eight times had
basically brainwashed tank pen and then
God Hank Pam to bring his wife Janet Van
Dyne to the headquarters of Ultron so
Ultron could take the consciousness of
Janet Van Dyne and put it in the body of
a robot that Ultron had created named
jacosta who is a character that's still
around in Marvel Comics but hasn't been
relevant for like 40 years so because of
that what Ultron ended up doing was of
course he was defeated by Hank Pam and
all those guys but this is one of those
instances where Dan Abnet is drawing on
that and in fact this is why ultron's
even able to do it in the first place
because he was able to almost pull it
off before and he's actually successful
here with the Consciousness transfer
that takes place really with uh the high
evolutionary more or less having a gun
put to his head Ultron ends up taking
over the body of Adam Warlock and
literally when that happens it's now
Ultron running around with the powers of
Adam Warlock now those are the guys who
are familiar with Ultron as an entity in
Marvel your initial thought is probably
no Ultron hates sentient life but one of
the things that was established in this
comic is that when Ultron took over the
armor of Tony Stark what he realized is
that there is some benefit to organic
life and in fact merging the two
together would make Ultron more powerful
than he's ever been even taking into
account his adamantium body and so
taking over the body of Adam Warlock was
done because Ultron perceives Adam
Warlock as the perfect being given the
amount of power he has at his disposal
all of his capability these the problem
with this is that Ultron can't readily
use all the powers of Adam Warlock
because Adam Warlock still doesn't have
all of his powers they're not fully
coalesced and fully formed so it's like
putting a gun that's in pieces in the
hands of somebody who doesn't know how
to reassemble that gun they're not going
to be able to use it right or at least
not use it effectively and so what
Ultron also indicates here what he
reveals is that it's not simply him just
stopping with where he is that what he
wants to do is he actually wants to
duplicate himself multiple times and
create an army of Ultron possessed Adam
warlocks which literally is being done
at this point in time that's his goal
and so while you end up coming to this
realization of is that while
everything's been going on here increase
space right this entire story has been
taking place essentially surrounding the
cree Empire that you also end up finding
out all these other races Across the
Universe took notice the Shia the badoon
the Scrolls the whole nine yards because
remember the cree are one of the oldest
and most powerful races in the universe
so with them just kind of going silent
right just disappearing nothing comes in
nothing comes out it makes people a
little concerned right it'd be like if
here in the real world Russia just went
dark they never talked to anybody no
information got in no information got
out your initial thought is like okay so
like Russia's about to Nuke the world
man because this is kind of creepy like
that's basically what this means that's
how the universe is interpreting this
but remember because of the energy
barrier that was created by the Phalanx
around cree's face these races can't
just go in there but fortunately for
them health is arriving in the form of
Richard Ryder and Gamora and draxa
destroyer and all those guys okay so a
little bit of exposition here so when it
came to Annihilation Conquest while we
are covering the main story itself there
were tie-ins which honestly aren't
really all that interesting at all but
one of those tie-ins dealt with Richard
Ryder that one was kind of cool at least
the first issue was because basically
you ended up having the destruction of
the whole Nova Corps but all those
individuals out there right the world
mind of the Nova core basically the
source of the Nova course power was
murdered with uh with Richard Ryder so
he's literally the only Nova left and
he's astronomically powerful the problem
with this is that Gamora was taken as
one of the select of the Phalanx so
initially she went after Richard Ryder
but of course Drax was made a select as
well given how powerful they were that
story basically dealt with Richard Ryder
going against Gamora and Drax and then
basically introducing or at least
bringing back warlock now warlock as a
member of the technarch because they're
so similar right it's like speaking
Portuguese and Portugal versus
Portuguese in Brazil you can understand
each other but it's just the dialects
are a little bit different because of
that warlock was able to purge the
Phalanx virus from Richard Ryder who'd
become infected along with Gamora and
Drax the Destroyer and that's why
they're all here the person that's with
warlock is basically just like this guy
that warlock turned into kind of a good
guy and is more or less raising him as a
son that's really all it is but because
of the similarities between Phalanx
technology and technology technology
this allows warlock to actually Grant
entry even if only on a smaller scale to
like Richard Ryder and those guys so
they can get in decree space once they
arrive there it's one of those
situations where it's like okay how can
we possibly come out on top with this
because you've basically got Ultron
running around in a body where he has
cosmic energy at his disposal the
Richard Ryder does jump in and it's
because of all the enhancements of
Richard Ryder that he's even able to
stand a chance in the first place but
that chance Falls pretty quickly and so
this leads to warlock jumping in now
warlock of course being a member of the
technarchy and not even really having a
physical form it's a malleable form it
can be adjusted so think of it as like a
machine version of like water or putty
that when he goes against Ultron he
comes to the rapid realization that he
cannot defeat Ultron in the conventional
sense right he cannot beat Ultron by
force and so he has to find an
alternative means now before we get to
that which is actually one of the cooler
parts in the story you do switch over to
this moment where the high evolutionary
is talking to philavel and it's just
like okay uh this is my way out so hey
look girl uh I wish you the best this is
not my fight it never was peace
literally he pieces out in like two
panels
literally he says final Bell I'm sorry
my hands were tied I genuinely hope your
efforts to unseat that monster are
successful but this is not my war and it
never was it is your fight and Adam will
guide you and he just teleports out
right he just he gets while the
getting's good but what also ends up
happening is Phila Vel sort of
communicates with Moondragon but not
really right Moondragon is basically
dead and the reality here is that final
Veil is not really talking to Heather
Douglas per se it's really more just
kind of her coming to terms with
everything that's going on but she is
communicating with a force and this
force is effectively guiding her to the
decision that she needs to make and this
Force really starts to kind of emanate
Itself by a sort of light that emerges
around phylavel and so as this conflict
continues to rage on you do have warlock
facing off against Ultron right jumping
back to that and warlock starts to
realize okay the Ultron Essence inside
of Adam Warlock is something that I
cannot defeat and so what he does is he
infects Ultron with the transmode virus
a virus that basically belongs to
Warlock himself but allows warlock to
effectively override individuals or even
machines and what that does is it forces
the Ultron Essence out of Adam Warlock
which basically flees now because Adam
Warlock is an empty husk at the moment
he literally just collapses but this is
when we find out what the force was that
was guiding file a valve which
ultimately we're told by Dan Abnet prior
to everything that was going on because
Adam Warlock felt like this is what
things might be leading to he ended up
having his essence or his soul placed
within the quantum bands of phyllable
now this is an important thing to
understand here when it comes to the
quantum bands in Marvel Comics this is
the kind of situation you run into so
sometimes the quantum bands are a thing
that have a practical purpose and they
allow you to fly and do some really cool
stuff and punch really hard and you're
just kind of like a space version of
Superman other times they're a MacGuffin
it's a way for you to write yourself out
of a hole and that's exactly what Dan
Abner did here he was literally like
okay so we're gonna have Ultron take
over the body of Adam Warlock how the
hell do I get myself out of this I know
we'll put the soul about some warlock in
the bracelets of philodel and she will
use those bracelets to resurrect him
from Dad and that's exactly what she
does she takes the soul and she pushes
it out of Warlock and Adam Warlock comes
back because you know hashtag comic book
logic in all seriousness though Adam
Warlock does ultimately return and there
is room for Dan Abnet to make this case
because Adam Warlock has done this
multiple times Adam Warlock literally
puts his own soul in the soul gem fairly
consistently in Marvel Comics for
basically safe keeping or different
things along those lines it's kind of
his home so it's not like Dana Abner I
mean I'm just kind of busting his balls
but it's not like Dan admin is just sort
of pulling this out of nowhere that's
kind of where that comes from right just
sort of the the Adam Warlock Soul Stone
McGuffin that you do see in Marvel
Comics from time to time but the cool
thing about this is that again Ultron
ever The Escape Artist hunting out there
for a way to return himself ends up
stumbling across the cree Armada that's
led by Ron and the accuser with the 15
000 centuries now the centuries
themselves are immune to the influence
of the Phalanx that's true but practice
the person who controls them is not
while she is immune to the Phalanx she's
not immune to Ultron Ultron actually
seizes control of praxagora and in doing
so that gives him control of the
entirety of the cree Sentry Army right
and remember these are the ones that
were able to purge a world of the
Phalanx in 10 minutes that's literally
what you're talking about right just
that level of power and so Ultron sees
in control of those of those centuries
ends up setting proxagora systems to
self-detonate which blows up Ron and the
accuser and his forces escaped by the
skin of their teeth and then Ultron has
all these sentries basically merged into
One Singular entity which basically
turns out to be a giant version of
Ultron one thing I do want to establish
here
I did love Dan abnet's work on
Annihilation this one was okay and it
felt more like Dan admit was just kind
of going towards your standard
run-of-the-mill comic book story but it
is fun because at this point everybody's
kind of like okay so like we're screwed
this is a giant version of Ultron we
struggled against the regular size one
how in the world are we possibly going
to be able to defeat this one because
literally everybody that tries to go
against him gets completely and totally
destroyed there's no way for them to
come out on top against this guy but
what ends up happening is it all
basically comes down to wraith again
this is the story that introduces him to
Marvel Comics uh and this is the story
where we really get to see him kind of
exercise his abilities that using his
exalon tendrils what it does is it can
find the essence of Ultron inside of his
own body so that Ultron can't escape at
that point things transition to Phi
level and phylavel basically channels
the energy of every Cree who's died on
the planet into a weapon and a source of
Destruction now again this is Dan Abnet
building on existing stuff back in 1990
and 1991 you had Mark gruenewald and
Greg capullo who were working on the
Quasar volume 1 Series in issue number
19 one of the things that was
established is that those individuals
who basically have a sufficient level of
energy can actually have that energy
stored within the quantum bands which
can be used to either resurrect them or
to channel that energy into increased
power what Dan Adnan is doing here is
basically expanding on that and
essentially offering this idea that
phylaval can do more than Wendell Vaughn
could have which is that she can Channel
The Life Energy of every single Creed
that died across the planet and used it
against Ultron and in doing that it is
enough to kill him right it's enough to
destroy Ultron in its entirety and so
with Ultron effectively eradicated the
entirety of the Phalanx literally just
shuts down right they have no leader no
one given the commands they literally go
inert like draxton Destroyer is waving
his hand in front of them and the
Phalanx can't see him now what Dan Abner
is also missing here is really the fact
that draxxa Destroyer is legitimately
invisible so there's no way for for the
failings to see him in the first place
but the thing about this is that once
this is done that's when you kind of get
into this little bit of an epilogue it
really does kind of focus on philoville
writing a letter to Moondragon hey I
miss you you know it sucks that you died
and I'm keeping you in my heart forever
about a little lock but the important
thing about this is that Phila Vel and
Adam Warlock are brought together by
Peter Quill in order to form what will
go on to become the Guardians of the
Galaxy after which they'll promptly
leave so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace